What's up, Marvel fans.
We're here with J.K. Simmons,
who plays Jay Jonah Jameson.
What was it like to come
back for the Spider-Man film?
Always a pleasure,
whatever incarnation.
I hope they keep
reincarnating JJJ.
Now what's the difference
between this Jay Jonah Jameson
and the one you
played previously?
Only the hair, really.
So this film is so massive.
What was it like working with
this incredible ensemble?
Well, I'll tell
you I was in and out.
I still haven't met 2/3
of the cast of this movie.
I'm hoping I get that
opportunity tonight.
So who are you
excited to see tonight?
That kid to play Spider-Man
whatever, his name is,
and you know the 75 bad guys,
some of whom are old leftovers
like myself, and some new ones.
Throughout your
Spider-Man journey,
do you have a favorite moment?
Can't pick one.
Not going to even try.